nicolas mirkovic cofondateur de l' ong
solidarité kosovo auteur du livre le
martyre du kosovo bon soir nicolas et
mirko vite merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors déjà comment
s'annonce et pourparlers bon on est dans
une situation un peu compliquée et les
deux parties donc la partie et lé
représentant de la partie sécessionniste
du kosovo vont se rencontrer pour la
première fois c'est la première fois que
la douleur faut-il le nouveau premier
ministre va rencontrer alexandre gucci
je rêve en discuter sur ce sujet du
kosovo
on sait que pendant pas mal de temps les
discussions ont été suspendues suite à
la décision d'imposer des droits de
douane sur les produits venus du kosovo
en même temps venant de servi au kosovo
en même temps il ya plus d'une quinzaine
de pays qui ces derniers ces dernières
années ont retiré leur reconnaissance du
kosovo
donc la situation est très compliquée si
on rajoute par dessus cela le fait que
hashim thaci soit possiblement inculpés
par le tribunal spécial pour les crimes
commis par les a menés pendant les
guerres des années 90 on est dans une
situation vraiment vraiment compliqué et
le fait que les états unis ne mettent
pas réussi à organiser cette réunion se
met il ya quinze jours avec la france et
l'allemagne vont essayer dé parvenir
nous promet quelque chose de là c'est
intéressant je pense que dans les
prochains jours alors déjà la question
qu'on peut se poser pour quelles raisons
la serbie refuse à elle depuis
maintenant plus de 12 ans tout même de
reconnaître l'indépendance du kosovo
parce que la guerre a été déclenchée
contre la serbie est une guerre illégale
n'oubliez pas que le cieux au second à
une forme d'indépendance aujourd'hui
mais qui n'est pas reconnu par
l'ensemble des pays de l'onu
c'est parce que l'otan a bombardé
illégalement la serbie et a appris il y
avait une guerre civile dans en serbie
ya une partie des albanais qui habitait
le sud de la serbie qui voulaient leur
indépendance n'était pas forcément la
majorité des albanais je rappelle que
beaucoup d'abeilles qui sont morts
pendant la guerre était d allemagne
était fidèle à benton qui voulait vivre
en veau l'entendement avec les serbes
qui n'étaient pas des ultranationalistes
l'otan est arrivé
a choisi à former soutenu armés la
fraction aux militants nationalistes des
albanais du kosovo qui ont décrété du
genre ne manquent il y avoir un pays qui
s'appelle au kosovo imaginez demain que
la seine-saint-denis déclare son
indépendance de la france que le
limousin déclare son indépendance de la
france sans aucune base historique en
plus parce que au chrso si vous regardez
dans les livres d'histoire ça n'existe
pas un pays qui s'appelle le kosovo ça
n'existe en une langue que sera un
peuple que ce voire sont des inventions
de bdg aux politiciens de washington et
l'union européenne qui pensent qu'avec
des bombes ils peuvent régler des
problèmes et qu'ils ont inventé ce pays
regardez pas ce pays qu'elle factice qui
20 ans plus tard n'a toujours aucune
légitimité la russie ne reconnaît pas le
le kosovo pas plus que la chine
l'algérie l'espagne chi le vatican ne
reconnaît pas l'indépendance du kosovo
et je le répète plus d'une quinzaine de
pays ont retiré leur reconnaissance du
kosovo c'est une opération de
déstabilisation atlantiste pour
contrôler les balkans et on voit bien
que ça ne marche pas le kosovo a reçu
par tête d'habitant plus dead que
l'europe avec le plan marshall à la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
regardez où et et l'europe vingt ans
plus tard regarder où le kosovo le
kosovo est une des régions les plus
pauvres d'europe aujourd'hui c'est une
catastrophe
atlantiste et bruxelles comme washington
essaie de tout faire pour rêver pour
colmater la brèche mais là le problème
est bien plus profond que ça ça va pas
se régler juste avec les plus réunion
même si angela merkel et emmanuel macron
les maîtres alors leurs meilleurs
efforts justement et on voit que c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour l'europe de
régler ce problème est de trouver une
solution justement quel rôle joue la
france et l'allemagne dans cette
rencontre et quelles sont leurs intérêts
respectifs
l'allemagne est à la présidence de
l'union européenne en ce moment et donc
du coup je pense qu'elle voudrait régler
ce problème qui est un problème
important n'oubliez pas que le kosovo et
la serbie sont sur la voie de
l'intégration dans l'union européenne
que cette intégration est impossible
tant qu' il n'ya pas l'unanimité des
pays européens or cinq pays européens
aujourd'hui ils ne reconnaissent pas
l'indépendance du kosovo donc du coup le
kosovo ne pourrait de fait jamais
intégré l'union européenne ce qui n'est
pas dans les projets de l'allemagne
emmanuel macron a clairement dit
vous voulez régler ce problème ils
voient ça aussi comme une épine dans le
pied de l'union européenne et il a la
prétention quand même d'essayer d'être
une voix de l'état pour résoudre des
problèmes de discorde en europe il
voudrait montrer qu'il est un homme fort
de l'union européenne et donc c'est pour
ça que c'est laid cette première réunion
se sont passées à paris à deux jours
avec avec un de leur retire aujourd'hui
avec aleksandar vucic marre on veut
montrer qu'il est un homme fort et qu'il
est capable de régler les différends
entre pays européens
alors l'inculpation du président kosovar
par la justice internationale pour
crimes contre l'humanité
est ce qu'elle peut être de nature à
venir troubler ces négociations selon
vous mais bien évidemment
figurez vous que le chef qui a été
soutenu par des personnalités comme
bernard henri lévy comme le des
présidents comme jacques chirac massimo
d'alema tout l'establishement politique
il ya 20 ans a soutenu cet homme comme
un libérateur comme la personne qu'il
fallait aller défendre parce qu'ils
étaient opprimés
parce qu'il était persécuté soi-disant
par le par la yougoslavie par menad et
on se rend compte vingt ans plus tard
que cet homme serait inculpé de crimes
de guerre de crimes contre l'humanité
les accusations contre lui sont
terrifiants ans par deux le kidnapping
de ma salle de torture et ça c'est
l'homme que l'occident a dépendu donc
tout cela apporte de l'eau évidemment au
moulin des cernes qui disent que depuis
le début c'est un groupe d'extrémistes
albanais qui on tue son soulevés qui ne
représente pas l'ensemble des abonnés
qui sont au kosovo que les attentistes
en décidé d'armer et de financer cette
personne pour pour qu'elle arrive à ses
fins et qui ont inventé suffit de
pousser aussi la personne sur laquelle
s'est appuyée l'otan la france
l'allemagne les états unis pour créer
cet état factice est un criminel de
guerre
toute l'histoire du kosovo indépendant
s'écroule et ça obligera les instants
sans talent l union européenne les pays
qui ont participé à cette guerre à se
remettre sérieusement en cause parce que
6,8 ont pour crimes de guerre ceux qui
l'ont soutenu qu'ils étaient dans les
chancelleries allemand françaises
américaines sont complices de crimes de
guerre merci nicolas abi convient
d'avoir été avec nous et nous avoir
éclairé sur ce sujet merci à vous